[Musique]
bonjour Sandrine Gomez bonjour Damien et
on ne récolte que ce qu'on sème à la
ligne de la presse internationale ce
matin finalement sont relancement de
Boris Johnson
qui bien sûr à la Une de toute la presse
britannique ce matin on va commencer à
regarder elle a une du gardien par
exemple qui titres pas le bon moment
c'est comme ça que Boris Johnson a
expliqué qu'il l'abandonnait on peut
également lire ici quand s'effaçant il
est vite finalement une humiliation
probable si Boris Johnson affirmé avoir
obtenu le soutien de sang en deux
députés tourisme deux au-dessus du seuil
nécessaire seul 60 avait en réalité
publiquement déclaré le soutenir du côté
de la presse tabloïde c'est un peu pâte
pitié ici en titre Boggio c'est un nom
en gros on ne croit pas que ce soit
Boris Johnson qui est finalement décidé
tout seul d'abandonner on lui a dit
clairement non ce journal explique que
si l'ancien Premier ministre a jeté
l'éponge c'est parce qu'il ne serait pas
en mesure de former un futur
gouvernement avec des députés en colère
un départ qui laisse presque seul en
piste qui sunac bien sûr il se prépare
pour le 10 dans une Street c'est ce que
titre le Time ce matin journal
conservateur qui ne manque pas de
souligner ici l'amertume de Boris
Johnson qui a blâmé le manque d'unité
des candidats alors ici on nous parle de
ces agitations tout le weekend de Boris
Johnson qui a tout fait pour revenir
dans le jeu le Time se rapporte qu'il a
proposé en vain un accord aussi bien un
Riché sounac et il aurait aussi demandé
à Penny mordante l'autre candidate de se
retirer à son profit et tout cela bien
sûr n'a pas marché on va voir de façon
un peu plus caricaturale ce que ça donne
du côté des dessinateurs britanniques
voici donc un dessin signé Mac on voit
les poubelles qui s'accumulent au 10
dans l'instrude avec une nouvelle
poubelle qui vient de s'installer
regardez toutes les réservée vous le
voyez au nouveau Premier ministre il y
en a trois déjà cette année il y en aura
bientôt trois cette année donc on
imagine donc deux femmes Theresa May
liste et puis Boris Johnson un fils
sélectif donc à propos de nouveaux
gouvernement à la Une également l'Italie
donc il y a un nouveau gouvernement
d'extrême droite et Emmanuel Macron qui
a déjà donc rencontré la nouvelle
présidente du conseil José Meloni cette
rencontre de dernière minute en catimini
elle s'étale à la ligne de la presse
italienne ce matin c'était hier soir le
Corriere de l'alcera titre sur cette
rencontre mélodie Macron premier tête à
tête intense il aura duré plus d'une
heure rencontre informel donc par parce
que non prévu mais qui a permis écrit ce
journal de ne pas se perdre dans trop de
considérations car il fallait surtout
briser la glace tous les principaux
dossiers nous dit-on européen ont été
abordés l'énergie chère le soutien à
l'Ukraine les questions migratoires mais
aussi la situation économique les
présidents italiens se sont mis d'accord
sur
cette envie de collaborer sur les grands
défis communs au niveau européen alors
cette photo de la rencontre entre les
deux dirigeants on la voit aussi ce
matin elle a une de la Républica Meloni
une leçon d'Europe alors ici on revient
plus précisément sur ce gouvernement
souverainiste ou figure à des postes
clés des ministres bruxello compatibles
notamment aux Affaires étrangères
européens et à l'économie et concernant
la rencontre avec Emmanuel Macron alors
ici on insiste plutôt sur le pragmatisme
Damien ce qui conduisent aujourd'hui
Rome et Paris ne s'aiment pas certes
mais ils sentent qu'ils ont besoin l'un
de l'autre Emmanuel Macron qui est
toujours en Italie qui est prévu une
autre rencontre aujourd'hui cette fois
avec le Pape François alors c'est la
troisième rencontre entre le pape
François et Emmanuel Macron alors c'est
le journal La Croix qui titres sur cette
rencontre ce matin entre donc entre les
deux il y a des accords mais aussi des
désaccords on s'interroge va-t-on
assister à un bras de fer politique
Emmanuel Macron lui nous dit le journal
catholique fait de la com mais le pape
lui veut essayer de ramener le président
français vers ce qu'il ne fait pas sur
le droit chemin on parle ici des
dossiers sur l'euthanasie autre dossier
qui les oppose c'est le sort des
migrants dernière ligne droite cette
fois avant le verdict des au Brésil et
la campagne se fait de plus en plus
violente avant le second tour dimanche
oui alors cette violence elle a commencé
dès l'arrivée au pouvoir de Jaïa
bolsonaro en réalité c'est le journal
Libération qui donne la parole ce matin
à des exilés brésiliens notamment en
Europe il raconte ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à avoir du quitter leur
pays car la haine et la violence était
trop forte alors ici on dénonce des
violences vis-à-vis de mouvants
mouvements sociaux des indigènes des
chercheurs et c'est le cas de cette
femme ici elle s'appelle Larissa bon
mardi auteur d'un atlas sur
l'utilisation des pesticides au Brésil
elle a les menacer surveiller et même
intimidé par l'industrie agroalimentaire
elle a donc depuis trouvé refuge en
Belgique alors cette violence est
vraiment le mot qui revient le plus dans
cette fente campagne car on assiste nous
dit le gardien de ce matin un clash de
deux Brésil les électeurs figurez-vous
et même les gangsters n'ont jamais été
autant divisé à l'occasion d'élection
alors justement le gardien est allé à la
rencontre de ces gangsters leur a donné
la parole et l'un d'eux estime que
leur vie et plus facile depuis l'arrivée
de bolsonaro plus facile de se procurer
des armes et des munitions mais tout de
même ils ont le sens civique selon eux
et bien celui qui gouverne pour les
pauvres des favelas c'est quand même
c'est quand même l'oula donc c'est toute
une société qui s'oppose nous dit le
gardiennes les pauvres votent Lula les
riches votre bolsonaro les hommes les
hommes les Noirs pardon non les Noirs
les femmes les catholiques vote Lola
quand les hommes et les blancs et les
évangéliques choisissent bolsonaro voilà
scrutin dans 6 jours maintenant et qu'on
suivra sur France 24